Please welcome, Drew Barrymore.
(audience cheering)
Hi.
The design.
Hi, hi.
(Drew giggles)
Oh my god, thank you. Thank you.
I don't know if anyone got a glimpse
of the beginning of season one,
but I went real hard by myself here.
I looked nuts. We were all nuts.
It was September of 2020.
We had this really intimate setting
and yet one day we hoped that maybe we could ever get here.
So to our very first New York studio audience,
thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, thank you so much.
It's a total dream.
One, I never thought we'd get to,
but here we are in our season two,
and it is such a privilege to be back
in my new hometown of New York.
I love it here so much.
I don't know if you could tell from my accent,
but I'm from California
(audience laughs)
and we're just celebrating
everything about hometowns.
We kicked off in my hometown of Los Angeles
and we're here now.
And, you know,
I just want to celebrate the whole country
and celebrate the fact that there is no place like home.
And that emotional storytelling for me is gonna be
a huge thread for this season.
And we actually get to leave the studio.
(audience laughs)
So I want to take it as far vast and wide
as they'll possibly let us.
And here we are, starting in New York.